hey guys and gals gigantic here with
just a quick update to video so one
question i get asked quite often by you
guys is if a website would ask me to
join them and pay me to make videos for
them would i accept it and for the most
part i've said no i've had a few
requests from websites to join them
already but i've always refused because
these reviews are my hobby and i always
wanted it to stay that way i never
intended to do any of these reviews for
money or get pressured to make reviews
on a schedule because i wouldn't enjoy
as much and that would obviously cause a
dip in my quality so in my mind the only
way i would accept anyone paying me to
do these videos is if one i would be
able to stay on youtube so i wouldn't
have to leave all you guys behind two i
could continue doing my videos the way i
wanted without having to compromise on
my style and three i can make reviews at
my own pace like i am now with no
pressure to keep on a schedule that's
when my only real options would be
either the youtube partnership program
which was out the question since i used
so much copyrighted clips that they
wouldn't touch me or some anime company
allowing me to use their clips and
paying me to do these videos which was a
highly unlikely and stupid thought so
imagine my shock when stars media who if
you don't know owned the anime
distribution company manga entertainment
contacted me and asked if i would join
their network where they would help
monetize my account and help give me
free advertising and in the future allow
me to gain access to their anime clips
without having to worry about copyright
to which i said hell the [ __ ] yes so
yeah
that happens a big thank you to stars
media manga entertainment for picking me
up and letting me do what i do for you
guys while being able to stay on youtube
anyway with that announcement out of the
way let's talk about new videos and the
future of this channel recently i
haven't had the time to work on new
videos since i had to put all my efforts
to catching up on university stuff after
i worked overtime to finish the
countdown for you guys but i actually
have a few new reviews scripted out to
finish when i get the chance but here's
the thing in the future i want to try
and stray away from being purely a
reviewer which is why if you haven't
noticed i've been experimenting with
different concepts recently for example
my rants were just a way for me to bring
out discussions and get the community
involved while also giving a chance to
let some of you guys get some exposure
which is why i feature a video response
after every rant and to my surprise has
got an overwhelmingly positive response
in fact they're getting more views than
my reviews are it also seems like you
also liked my amv and countdown as well
so i'll probably do more of them too but
don't worry i don't intend to stop
reviewing it's just that if i put a bit
of a variety into my work it might
motivate me to work more on videos
rather than releasing a new review every
two or three months or god forbid taking
another eight-month break like i used to
do because i was burned out plus at the
end of the day i wanted to become a
channel for entertainment about anime
topics in general rather than just a
purely reviewing channel so i hope you
guys don't mind me experimenting with
new concepts now and then but just so
you know that whatever i do my end goal
is to entertain you guys in one way or
another oh and before i forget during my
last live stream a few of you tried to
convince me to make a facebook fan page
since not everyone is a twitter user
which are finally gone and done so link
to that is in the description below as
well and any major announcements will go
on there along with on my twitter i
think that's all for now thank you all
for sticking with me especially those of
you who made it through my epic
countdown keep commenting and subbing
them if you still haven't posted a video
response to my dub haters rants well you
better do so soon because my new rant is
coming up but until then i'll see you
all next time